what what's next for you are you going  going on a little break you'll be  following the candidates or what are you  up to  yeah i'll be um  following the candidates full time  [Laughter]  for for the next couple of weeks  um it's not like i've been playing too  much um  but i feel like i've like constantly  been  [Music]  like a little bit  a little bit sick lacking energy um  for for a while and i was feeling okay  during the tournament but i think  like  the lack of surplus energy kind of kind  of caught up  with me at  at the end so  that would be  chess wise that would be the only  important thing for me the next  one and a half months or so it's just to  to gain some energy before i'm i'm  playing again  the next tournament will be the olympia  for norway yeah uh i won't be playing  the next uh japanese chest story event